[Musica]
lo vedete questo simbolo questo
diagramma cinese tradizionale
una stessa parola che significa sia
musica che gioia
d'altronde questo accostamento non c'è
poi tanto lontana questa sinonimia se
pensiamo a quante altre lingue in quante
altre culture suonare e giocare sono lo
stesso verbo
spilli due play di nuovo un analogia
gioiosa giocare suonare insomma
divertirsi ma perché è proprio gioia la
parola cui accostiamo la musica è
veramente solo così un gioco un
divertimento un'allegria o c'è
dell'altro
io sono il pianoforte da quando avevo
quattro anni è sicuramente la cosa più
bella che ho imparato a fare nella vita
ma riusciamo a renderci tutti conto di
quanto possa anche essere duro difficile
e tormentato il cammino di crescita del
piccolo musicista
disciplina impegno sacrifici enormi
solitudini
una pratica quotidiana di esercizi e
spendo avanti ripetizioni in esauste
stress psicofisico anche proprio a
livello agonistico
sempre lì a perfezionare un gesto
a controllare un suono
a rilassare questo o quel muscolo giorno
dopo giorno errore dopo errore
gioia
perché non chiamarla anche
fatica sfida sacrificio
perché poi esiste anche una fatica molto
più sottile che non si vede ad
accompagnare sempre il percorso di
crescita dell'artista sto parlando del
cammino che il musicista fa dentro di sé
il cammino interiore alla ricerca della
sua propria voce quella che gli serve
per avere sempre qualcosa da dire
comunicare un messaggio grazie alla sua
arte
con il proprio talento
ma questo talento che cos'è sicuramente
è un dono preziosissimo che ogni giorno
dobbiamo innaffiare coltivare con
gratitudine amore dedizione
costanza ma il talento
può anche essere un limite in qualche
modo
se n'è una linea una demarcazione con
tutta un'altra grande fetta di umanità e
come se il talento mettesse per una
qualche specifica dote abilità capacità
degli umani oltre un confine in una
sorta di confort don dove alcune cose ci
riescono meglio ci sono più facili
naturali pro può capitare di sentirsi
veramente molto soli perché può capitare
di lasciare inesplorato
tutto quel vivere fatto anche dei nostri
tanti non talenti tutto quello che siamo
tutta la vita che abbiamo oltre quel
confine
allora perché proprio gioia perché non
solitudine tormento
coraggio di andare oltre ma andiamo a
sentirlo nella musica stessa quella che
è il risultato di tanta ricerca sforzo
come ci fa sentire cosa ci fa provare
soltanto gioia qui si
[Musica]
[Applauso]
anche qui allegria
[Musica]
ma qui
come vi sentite come va
è sempre beethoven
oppure rachmaninov
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che diceva che la poesia la sorella
della musica
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e la madre alla tristezza
[Musica]
ma quante altre emozioni quanti altri
stati d'animo può farci provare la
musica per esempio da questo ostinato
procopio
[Musica]
o da questa sessione
chopin
[Musica]
rabbia
ira
[Musica]
disperazione
[Applauso]
[Musica]
la pace
un momento di tranquillità
si fa respirare
[Musica]
oppure ci portano a ballare
ho un altro ballo
valzer
[Musica]
angoscia
presagio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
paura
[Musica]
a la quiete del sogno
dolce
[Musica]
tele sospesi
appesi a un filo
[Musica]
o ancora una cavalcata appassionata
[Applauso]
[Musica]
stavolta
grazie
ma come vi sentite voi siete sentiti
cosa avete provato se dite sono pieni di
allegria
contentezza felicità
poi c'era dell'altro
quando nella vita ascoltando della
musica come abbiamo fatto ora vi è
capitato di commuovermi
mi sono scese delle lacrime erano
lacrime di gioia
e di dolore
il punto è che non importa
quello che conta è che la musica ci
muove non ha importanza se quello che
abbiamo ascoltato ci è sembrato trista
agitato infuocato quello che conta è che
ci ha mosso qualcosa dentro che ci ha
fatto vivere un'emozione il fatto stesso
che la sentiamo passare questa energia
ci fa sentire vivi e in questo sentirci
vivi vulnerabili veri
indipendentemente da quale sia il nostro
stato d'animo incominciamo intravederla
la gioia che ci rende finalmente liberi
nel sentirci perché la musica alla
grande capacità di far provare delle
emozioni a chi la suona e chi l'ascolta
si riconnette con noi stessi ci fa
sentire compresi
ci fa ricolleghi ricollega a noi stessi
ci fa ricollegare a qualche nostra
fragilità ricordo del passato
vulnerabilità del presente perché ci
arriva così
nell'area con i suoni con delle
vibrazioni dagli strumenti musicali fino
ai nostri corpi perché tutto ciò che
vibra e vita
allora io voglio raccontarvi adesso un
aneddoto
nei miei tanti viaggi e confini del
mondo
oltre le frontiere delle società
civilizzate le barriere culturali e
sociali mi è capitato di incontrare
tanti tipi di umani diverse etnie
culture e religioni ma quelli che mi
sono sempre rimasti più impressi nel
cuore sono stati sempre i bambini che
nella loro
spontaneità sono così limpidi puri
sinceri
una volta mi trovavo
una township
sudafricana una sorta di favella in
sudafrica in una piccola scuola un
centro dei diritti umani un luogo molto
povero dove l'università di porth
elisabeth aveva fatto arrivare un
pianoforte ovviamente questi bambini non
avevano mai visto un pianoforte ne ha ma
non avevano mai visto una ragazza come
me suonare della musica classica non
parlando la stessa lingua ci siamo
capiti un po a gesti un po con delle
preghiere ma soprattutto anche con la
musica
allora io cominciai a suonare delle
melodie semplici
orecchiabili
divertenti e poi per tranquillizzarli un
po per calmarli di suonai la ninna nanna
di brahms questa
[Musica]
va bene conosciamo tutti no ma loro no
loro non avevano non l'avevano mai
sentita la cosa incredibile che dal
suono solitario del pianoforte questi
bambini si misero a cantare in coro
felici una loro cantilena una loro
canzone popolare che secondo loro faceva
proprio come il wigan lead di evans
brahms finalmente gli era sembrato di
riconoscere che cosa stavo suonando per
loro allora io li continua ad
accompagnare suonai con loro
perché questi tipi di canti così
semplici o armonicamente accessibili
[Musica]
sono uguali in tutto il mondo nella loro
semplicità cullano abbracciano tutti
senza limiti senza confini
e così anche grazie a questa esperienza
così dolce mi è sembrato di cominciare a
capire come mai così tante culture
associano nel loro linguaggio nella loro
scrittura
il concetto di musica quello di gioia ma
proviamo a fare anche tanti altri esempi
dei canti di montagna e l'inno nazionale
il coro della chiesa le canzoni da
stadio
la radio alta in macchina con gli amici
in vacanza cantare sotto la doccia
le preghiere con la nonna il karaoke
il rosario mariano in mantra le prove
con la band
cantare ballare e divertirsi tutti
insieme a un concerto in discoteca
forse la gioia è proprio quella che
grazie alla musica ci rende parte di un
tutto
dissolvendo delle resistenze delle
densità oltrepassando dei confini
improvvisamente ci fa trovare quel
qualcosa che ci riunifica
è come se quando quando la musica
riesce a spezzare tutto questo perché
noi non ci sentiamo più soli per i non
solo siamo vivi e libriamo delle
emozioni ma anche cantiamo risaniamo di
un coro universale e quando la musica ci
riesce e ci unisce in questo modo noi ci
sentiamo abbracciare un respiro più
ampio
ci sembra di continuare un qualcosa
nella voce negli occhi nelle mani degli
altri quelle ordinate io le campane
in questo passaggio di energia
facendo passare questa libertà vibrante
che chiamiamo musica ci ritroviamo
addosso un qualcosa
a cui non saprei dare nome più esatto
gioia
[Musica]
[Applauso]